expectativa y tensión en aumento así se
vive la recta final del caso de Glenn
Maxwell acusada de ayudar al magnate
Jeffrey Epstein abusar de 4 menores de
edad con la última audiencia cerrada su
destino queda ahora en manos del jurado
que determinará si es culpable o
inocente
el juicio comenzó el 29 de noviembre un
día que las víctimas del multimillonario
catalogaron como esperanzador
simbólicamente importante para todas las
sobrevivientes del mundo entero y en
particular los sobrevivientes de Jeffrey
Epstein que como yo fueron privadas de
un día en la corte pero tengo fe en el
sistema de justicia y sé que el jurado
llegar a una conclusión correcta
me da un tremendo alivio estar cerca de
ella poder verla en carne y hueso
incluso poder hablar con ella
mi primera vez que he hablado con ella
personalmente en 500 días desde que
comenzó su prisión preventiva
cargos están en juego entre ellos
conspiración tráfico sexual de menores y
tentar a un menor a viajar para
participar en actos sexuales ilegales
los fiscales han recordado sus vínculos
conecten con el que dicen se involucró
sentimentalmente y dirigió varios de sus
negocios el magnate se suicidó en una
cárcel en Manhattan en 2019 tenía 66
años y esperaba un juicio por abuso
sexual